when i was a kid i loved the television
show i loved the television show uh lost
in space
right and i had a weird dream that they
were shooting lost in space
at my dad's upholstery shop and i was
like
10. so i didn't have a dream that i was
in you know on the jupiter 2 with the
robinson family i had a dream they were
filming
at my dad's shop and there was uh there
were lights and there was a clapper
board and all that but there was there
was craft service
how in the world would i know there was
such thing as craft service
on a television show set i was gonna
make a fat joke but i'm not gonna do it
yeah yeah yeah about craft service yeah
but hey hey hollywood
but um they were there and i was sitting
talking with the with billy mummy
or mommy i'm not sure uh yeah and
we were just we were pals i wasn't with
will robinson so it was weird i had a
couple of things like that happen in my
uh
in my life later on i i ran into june
lockhart
who was in the dream too had a weird
dream that uh
i was at a party in a tuxedo and i
bumped into somebody and i said oh
excuse me the guy turned around it was
dean martin
and dean martin also in a tuxedo like he
always was said to me
thanks for having me here and i'm like
11 years old right
and uh years later during
uh one of the the last children's
miracle network we did at videopolis out
at disneyland there
um i i was wearing my tuxedo and i
bumped into it to a gentleman i said oh
excuse me turned around it's dean martin
and he says thanks for having me here so
when opportunities come around like
dukes of hazard when opportunities come
around like smallville which i said no
emphatically i said i don't want to be
part of the demise of the superman
legend i don't want to have anything to
do with small bill
you really turn to just turn it down
three times
wow i turned down the audition i said
i'm not gonna go audition
i'm not gonna take the no and then uh
then they said just read the pilot my my
agent said read the pilot
and i got to the part where uh
where uh i have the keys to the truck
that you gave
uh you gave clark on the wall and i
i said um he said so you're saying the
apple doesn't fall far from the tree and
i said no
i said i just want you to realize where
the money came from that bought that
truck
and at that point i knew that this was
not going to be the demise of superman
this was going to be something
that would firmly plant superman into
the psyche of watchers forever
that it in fact would be the best part
of the superman legend
um and at that point i i it wasn't like
oh gosh i want to be jonathan kent it
was like oh
this is the next thing this is the next
stepping stone for me um
so i didn't have any doubt in the world
that i was going to get it
even though there were there were other
people there and i i
and somehow michael somehow this is not
uh
it's not arrogance it's like seeing it
when i was 18 and i read dukes of hazard
i thought oh this is it
this is the springboard what i've been
working toward
uh gosh it's hard to explain no no
i absolutely understand it listen to me
there are some people
who think and you know i think i've been
both these people
that you're like this is me this is the
role i'm getting this role and then
there are a lot of people who think
oh my gosh but they're going to go out
to somebody else there's going to be so
many other people there but
you know you start thinking there's a
certain confidence and i think
certain um inadvertent i don't know if
it's inadvertent but it's
it's this brave sort of
intuition or feeling you get when you're
younger and you're
like excited about something i remember
in college saying to alexis combs
i remember her name sitting on the porch
and i go i'm gonna go to new york and
i'm gonna make it and she's like oh
okay she didn't talk like that she was
way smarter than me i don't know why i
made it i just i tried to differentiate
my voice she was just like
okay oh great michael that's great and
by the way uh
we we've texted in the last six months
and um
but i said no no no no i'm going to new
york
i know the odds i know all that stuff it
it it doesn't
it's not that's not about me i know what
i'm gonna do so there was a certain
and i go remember this moment because
you're gonna go oh my god i remember him
saying that because i felt it
it was just something i felt so i
understand that you had this feeling
that this is going to happen
yeah well you know you have to um they
say that success is when preparation
meets opportunity
right but there's another part to that
um i know a lot of very talented people
that that throw opportunity away with
both hands because they don't recognize
it
you've got to recognize you have to
expect
great things if you don't expect
great things if you look at you look at
life like ah what's going to happen
now
nothing is going to happen now certainly
nothing good but if you look at life
like i get like a little kid there's an
easter egg you know where's the easter
egg
i know there's an easter egg out here
because because they're supposed to be
so if you look at life that way then you
start recognizing the easter eggs
and you start realizing what you have
prepared for
so prep of success is when preparation
meets opportunity that you recognize
you